okay Lance Morissette brought her Jagged
Little Pill to Times Square for Dick
Clark's New Year's rockin Eve Bryan
Seacrest and she actually performed with
the Broadway cast yeah and some viewers
were as shocked at how much ABC bleeped
out in Canada the lyrics - you ought to
know we're not leaped out so here's what
Alana's saying I wish nothing but
the best for you both
[Music]
like me would she go down okay hmm so
here's what viewers on ABC heard or
didn't hear really I wish nothing but
the best for you both
I'll note a very shy man like me which
and actually they actually bleep out the
older version of me line as well yes
they bleep that old me very like
perverted and then down on you the
theater like I can understand them doing
the last one but anyways people are
wondering why ABC was overly sensitive
but then they missed a much bigger word
to bleep out when cast member lauryn
Patton started the same we have to bleep
it out guys but ABC they didn't do that
when it was
are you thinking
that was amazing
[Music]
okay yes so mom just went through there
so yeah I'm guessing ABC thought Lauren
was gonna sing a g-rated version yeah of
line but Lauren went for the f-word
live on TV Lauren told variety
afterwards that the f-bomb was that the
Lannisters request the warrant says she
told me to she said say it she said she
always thinks that and told me you're
gonna say it too so speaks yeah you
gotta do it I did she feel pressure to
do it I'm sure would you have something
would you have sung the f-bomb word if
you were there knowing it's all these
families that do use even wonder like
going back like could she get sued does
that happen like that's happened I'm
Super Bowl right when laughter like am
ia put up and go fingers
she got sued for the head no never so if
that's like you kind of going rogue like
EBC was not expecting you to do that but
she did cover herself a bit by saying
well this a which I don't get wildly why
the other lines were the older version
of me strange I don't know what that is
yeah maybe that was just a mistake yeah
I I can see the reasoning being like
it's gonna be all these families
watching and it is like ABC they're
known to be a bit more conservative when
it comes to those sorts of things but
what's a missed one Jessica says why
does she get censored notices the bleep
note takes the whole meaning of the song
it's just lyrics I remember cube
actually backed the year of the Grammys
that Alanis won all those words she was
gonna perform got to know and became a
big debate whether or not she was gonna
say the f-word and whatever broadcaster
wasn't thing is maybe CBS that year they
let it go through that thing that word
baby then censor and kind of way so yeah
that's like 1997 I think that was so 22
minute yeah so that word got through
again I tend to like the song to be
played the original way and also it is a
bit weird to hear someone else singing
it right okay in my mind is only ever
Alanis again Paulus's kind of nasty
lyrics always thought they were done
says I guess that's a little ironic
where's that rimshot where's the drew
himself now